ladies and Gentlemen please welcome
co-founder strive Asset Management Vivek
Prema Swami
[Music]
thank you guys for thank you for the
warm welcome I've been walking the Halls
feel like a lot of you know me this year
and then every fifth person comes up and
says are you cash Patel and I'm like no
no
I'm still I still don't know me
so it's good to be back I'm going to
tell you a little bit about my story
from from a few years ago
when I had to make a choice okay this is
going to be a speech about Choice by the
way
I had to make a choice in 2020. this is
back when I was a biotech CEO it was a
multi-billion dollar company I found it
I builted it from scratch
but in 2020 after George Floyd died
I was expected to make a statement in
favor of the black lives matter movement
there's a choice
I chose not to do it I said that our
purpose as a company
is to make medicines to make products
and services for people who need them
but that was the beginning of a
six-month Journey that culminated about
six months later
in three prominent advisors to my
company resigning
and I had to make a choice
was I going to speak through the filter
of corporate self-interest
or was I going to speak freely as a
citizen
and from that moment forward I chose to
speak freely as a citizen
thank you
I wrote woke Inc I wrote nation of
victims I traveled the country calling
out the woke industrial complex in
America I started a new company called
strive to take on BlackRock and the ESG
movement through the market itself
saying that it's not their job to tell
us to use our dollars and how we live
our lives
I called out the three secular religions
in America that have America in a
Chokehold today
the first of them is this woke racial
religion that says your identity is
based on your skin color that if you're
black you're inherently disadvantaged
that if you're white you're inherently
privileged no matter your economic
background or your upbringing that your
race determines who you are and what you
can achieve in life
it's one that congresswoman Ayanna
Presley of the squad summed up really
well when she said we don't want any
more Brown faces that don't want to be a
brown voice I do not fit her description
of what counts as a brown voice I assure
you that but it is a really clever move
in this religion
which is this if you your race goes from
being about your skin color
to being about the content of the ideas
you're allowed to espouse then any
disagreement with those ideas
automatically makes you a racist and
there is no greater damnation in modern
America than to be called a racist so
when given the choice between pledging
allegiance to this new religion
and being tarred with the Scarlet r
that's when everyday Americans started
to bend the knee and that's what created
this new Culture of Fear in America
when it then combined with the second
religion
that's a new secular religion in America
that says
the sex of the person you're attracted
to
has to be hardwired on the day you were
born it had to be or else it couldn't be
a civil right
but your own biological sex is
completely fluid over the course of your
lifetime it makes no sense unless it's a
religion it doesn't match up to reason
it matches up to religion and then it
makes the same move as the first
religion well you know what Peter Thiel
who's a man who's attracted to men The
Advocate magazine one of the leading
lgbtqia plus magazines
said that Peter Thiel is not gay after
he spoke at the RNC
because he did not represent the gay
voice
so now you're starting to see a pattern
which then brings us to the doorstep of
the third religion that has America in a
Chokehold and that is the newest one
that looks like it's here to stay until
we do something about it and we will
that is the climate religion in America
that says that we have to fight carbon
emissions at all costs in the United
States while we shift those same carbon
emissions to places like China that
supposedly even if you believe in this
religion you would have embraced nuclear
energy which is the best form of
carbon-free energy production known to
mankind
and yet these people oppose nuclear
energy what's really going on is that
the climate religion has about as much
to do with the climate as the Spanish
Inquisition had to do with Christ which
is to say nothing at all it is about
power Dominion control punishment and
apologizing for what we have achieved in
this country in the modern West as we
know it
so the real question is what's going on
what the heck is going on in our country
where these same religions not not
religions of Christ different religions
Arise at the same time what's really
going on here
the answer is that we are in the middle
of a national identity crisis in America
okay we are so hungry take it from me
I'm 37 years old I'm a millennial I was
born in 1985. I will tell you this my
generation
really every generation of Americans
today we're so hungry for a Cause
we're hungry for purpose
and meaning
and identity at a point in our national
history
when the things that used to fill our
hunger for purpose
faith
patriotism
hard work
family
these things have disappeared
we're hungry to be part of something
bigger than ourselves
yet we cannot even answer the question
of what it means to be an American today
this is an opportunity for the GOP this
is an opportunity for the conservative
movement to rise to the occasion and
fill that void with a vision of American
national identity that runs so deep that
it dilutes this woke poison to
irrelevance
I am all in on the America First agenda
believe me I'm an America First
conservative I will not apologize for it
but to put America first we now need to
ReDiscover what America is and that is
why last week I announced my run for U.S
president to deliver a national identity
that we are missing in this country
so what does it mean to be an American
it means you believe in Merit that you
get ahead in this country not on the
color of your skin but on the content of
your character and your contributions
and that is why as U.S president I have
pledged to get rid of affirmative action
in this country once and for all it is a
National Cancer on our soul and we are
done with it
it came into existence by an executive
order from Lyndon Johnson every
president since Lyndon Johnson could
have crossed it out I love the man I'm
going to come and talk to him about in a
second but I'm going to tell you
cross that out we're done with
affirmative action in America okay
that's the first thing
but back to the question what does it
mean to be American okay this is this is
the question it means we believe
that the people who we elect to run the
government whoever it is
ought to be the people who actually run
the government
radical idea in America who would have
ever thought
it's not the case today so the next time
we have an Anthony fauci or an American
Garland or a James Comey who goes far
beyond their constitutional scope
you need to do what a chief executive in
this country is constitutionally
empowered to do you fire them you fire
their employees you fire the managerial
industrial complex around them and I'll
tell you this even further thank you
very much
we got to go one step further than that
because when a managerial cancer gets so
bad in this country you can't just
reform that from on high I come from the
private sector I know this if you tell
me that somebody works for me and I
can't fire them
that means that they don't work for me
it means I work for them
it means I am their slave because I'm
responsible for what they do without
having any power to determine it well
that can't be the position that the U.S
president has put in when a managerial
cancer gets so bad you have one option
left in this country
you have to shut it down and I've
already said last week the first agency
we will shut down and need to shut down
in the United States is the U.S
Department of Education it has no reason
to exist
never should have existed
make a mistake it's better late than
never you shut it down and today I'm
ready to announce the second government
agency that I will shut down in this
country we should have done it 60 years
ago it's her Republicans and Democrats
alike we're going to get it done is
finally time to shut down the FBI in
America
create something new to take its place
because we are done with the J Edgar
Hoover Legacy to let this be a
self-governing nation again
what does it mean to be American it
means you believe in the rule of law
okay the people who enter this country
better down well come through the front
door because your First Act of entering
this country cannot be a law-breaking
one and I'll tell you this as a kid of
immigrants that is not racist that is
what it means to be American okay it
means that you believe the military in
this country
protects our border rather than somebody
else's border Halfway Around the World
it means you put American interests
first
you know talk about a legitimate use of
the U.S military you're going to call
the Mexican cartels a drug terrorist
organization
treat them like a terrorist organization
we can do it to Bin Laden we can do it
to soleimani we can do it to the Mexican
drug cartels South of the Border that is
how we end the fentanyl epidemic in this
country
if the military does one thing it
protects the soil we live on not
somebody else's soil that too is what it
means to be American
well what it means to be American it
means you believe in the Declaration of
Independence it means you believe in
1776 the Declaration of Independence of
today
is our declaration of independence from
China
if Thomas Jefferson were alive today
that is the Declaration of Independence
he would sign that is the Declaration of
Independence I will sign if I'm elected
as your next president because you know
what
we are in trouble when we have a
codependent relationship with our enemy
the Soviet Union they never put the
shoes on our feet they never put the
phones in our pocket we're in a
codependent relationship with our enemy
and co-dependent relationships do not
end well
the only question is who ends it first
the sooner we end it the better for us
the later we end it the better for them
and I think it is finally to say we are
done with relying on an enemy to power
our modern way of life some of this is
going to be easy
it's the easy stuff
abandon climate religion the climate
religion that shackles the United States
while leaving China untouched I don't
know why more Republicans can't just say
that aloud it's the thing you're not
supposed to say it's a sacred cow you
take that sacred cow to the
slaughterhouse where it belongs climate
religion is about actually shackling
America itself
some of this stuff is easy they send the
fentanyl across our Southern border they
send the digital fentanyl through Tick
Tock Financial fentanyl in the form of
the national debt that's created this
addictive relationship to China we
declare independence we're done with
financial fentanyl digital fentanyl
actual fentanyl some of this stuff we
can agree on
now I appreciate the Applause but I also
want to be really honest with you
my number one opposition I'm nine days
into this presidential campaign and the
number one opposition I get to what I
just told you actually comes from the
Republican Party a wing of the
Republican Party
that is so addicted to buying cheap
stuff from China and expanding into the
Chinese market
that they're not ready to make that
short run sacrifice I go further I think
it's important to be honest if we want
to declare independence from China that
means we got to be willing to ban most
U.S businesses from doing business in
China until the CCP Falls or until the
CCP radically reforms itself because
there is no easy way out other than
taking that band-aid and ripping it
right off I'm sorry Henry Kissinger
we're done with your experiment in
America
it is the only way out we got to start
thinking on the time scales of History
not the time scales of electoral Cycles
we don't need Chamberlain we need a
little bit of Churchill in this country
and you know what
if you're willing to make a sacrifice
the chances are you'll never have to
make it because the other side will fall
first and you can be willing to make a
sacrifice if you know what you are
sacrificing for
and that is this thing we call America
okay our inner animal spirit
it has been domesticated it has been
tamed by this new culture
that Embraces victimhood and rejects
Excellence our inner animal it has left
oceans to lift up places like China on
the other side of the world while their
culture of maoist victimhood came back
to Hold Us Down
I'll tell you this when we rallied
behind the cry to make America great
again
we did not just hunger for a single man
we hungered for the Unapologetic pursuit
of Excellence that is what it means to
be an American
thank you
I want to do something tonight I want to
address the I love the boisterous odds
on address it actually directly I
believe in free speech free speech is
what it means to be American so even if
you disagree with us saying stand up and
say it because you deserve to this is
the country we live in for a reason let
me address it right away okay you're
going to hear tomorrow night
from my good friend
Donald Trump a man who I took
inspiration from to do what I am doing
now if he hadn't done what he did in
2015 and 2016 as an outsider to Cayman
shake up the system I wouldn't have even
thought about doing what I'm doing today
and running for president that's just a
fact okay now next six months
it's possible as this goes you know
we'll get a little bit of name-calling
and you know what that's part of uh what
do you say locker room talk a little bit
of trash talk on the court got to have
some fun and handle it but I think if
you can handle a little bit of name
calling in this or have some fun you
probably shouldn't be the person sitting
across the table representing this
country in front of Xi Jinping either
but I will tell you something about my
friend
he is misunderstood across this country
I know him he cares deeply about
National Unity I know you care deeply
about National Unity I'm running for
president because I care deeply about
National Unity but here's the question
this is the question for the next year
and a half in the conservative movement
in the Republican Party
and in America
do we want a national divorce
or do we want a national Revival
it's not going to happen automatically
whatever it is it is going to be what we
choose it to be
that is the question today and I'll tell
you here's how we're not going to get
National Unity we're not going to get
National Unity with somebody showing up
in the proverbial middle
saying hey can't we all hold hands
compromise get along Kumbaya no that
ain't happening that ship has sailed
long ago
Yuan National Unity here's how you get
National Unity
you get National unity in this country
by embracing the extremism
the radicalism
of the ideals that set this nation into
motion 250 years ago Merit Free Speech
open debate self-governance over
aristocracy these are radical ideas most
of human history it was done the other
way Old World Europe didn't do it this
way we did it this way for a reason
because we're different we're Americans
and if we Embrace that
that is our formula to actually deliver
I think the most unifying thing we could
deliver for the country in 2024 and it's
this
don't believe it when they tell you it's
about Republicans and Democrats
artificial distinctions what really
matters in this country is a battle
between the managerial class
and the everyday citizen between the
great reset and the great Uprising
between the pro-american movement do you
believe in this country and are you
willing to stand for it or the
anti-American movement which apologizes
what this country stands for and here's
the good news I have for you
when you divide it up that way
instead of Republicans and Democrats you
got an 80 20 in our favor and you know
what's happened in 2024 you mark my
words I predict a 1980 style 1984 style
Landslide election in this country if we
get it right that is the single most
unifying thing we could deliver for our
nation going forward I'll tell you this
for the last 10 20 years in America
we have celebrated our diversity and our
differences so much that we forgot all
the ways were the same well you know
what revive the ways that we are the
same diversity is not our strength our
strength is what unifies us across our
diversity and you mark my words that one
the American Revolution it reunited us
after the Civil War it won US two world
wars in the Cold War it could still be
hoped for the Free World and if we can
revive that over fractious group
identity then nobody in the world is
going to defeat us that is American
exceptionalism thank you very much God
bless you God bless our great country
all the best thank you
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else